The word entheogenic
means god-facilitating.
And it's this idea that tools
and techniques of ecstasy
can act as conduits,
as mediation
catalysts for encounters
with the numinous.
They are essentially
god-hacks, OK?
It's this notion that
we are able to tweak
our subjective
experience to catalyze
a shift in consciousness that
leads us to kind of god-mode.
And as Mckenna says, "Do not
give in to the astonishment."
The realization that reality
is but a matrix of perception,
that we can pierce that veil,
that we can raise the stage
is astonishing.
It means we are
ontological engineers.
We are the music makers and
we are the dreamers of dreams
indeed.
We tumble down that rabbit hole.
We re-inscribe,
redefine, re-edit
the nature of that rabbit hole.
The wonderland becomes
our wonderland.
The hero's journey
becomes the map
for our own ecstatic
illumination.
And I love this notion.
You know, Mircia
Eliade, the philosopher,
talked about
techniques of ecstasy.
He described shamans as
literally ecstatic technicians
of the sacred.
This is my dream, right?
This notion that we actually
are able to create conditions,
to create spaces for all of us
to become ecstatic technicians
of the sacred.
That the passport
to the numinous
lies within and
that we can hack it.
That there is a god-hack.
Oof.
It's an entheogenic revolution.
Boundaries are being dissolved
and we are being reborn.
It is our birthright.
It is our birthplace.
We are as gods.
We might as well get good at it.
Cognitive ecstasy,
meta-cognitive ecstasy
is within.